today on the matt walsh show many people
are very upset after obama flouted every
coveted safety guideline to throw
himself a giant birthday party over the
weekend but i think there are some
important lessons we can take from this
which go beyond simple outrage and i'll
explain today also some truly inspiring
not to mention hilarious video of one
old guy who has no time for the less
gender nonsense you have to see this
i'll play that and the media claims that
children's hospitals are filling up with
covid patients is that even remotely
true plus a prison inmate gets 25 years
for beating a child rapist to death in
prison if you already feel like that
sentence is grossly unfair wait until
you hear the rest of the story and then
in our daily cancellation i will
confront nike over its latest commercial
which
you will not be able to watch without
dying of secondhand embarrassment all of
that and much more today on the matt
wall show
we're very excited to have a new sponsor
on the show today buy optimizers one of
the best things you can possibly do to
improve your health is get at least
seven hours of quality sleep every night
i rarely do which is why i am decaying
in front of your eyes
uh i know there are hundreds of reasons
why you might not get enough sleep i i
sleep i've as i said been there myself
but one of the biggest reasons
might be magnesium deficiency and i'm
always telling people this when they
complain about not getting enough sleep
i say how's your magnesium doing you see
magnesium is key to getting good sleep
but 75 of people are actually magnesium
deficient does any wonder so many people
have sleep problems to help fix sleep
problems and fully enjoy the calming
effects of magnesium i recommend
magnesium breakthrough by by optimizers
it's the only organic full spectrum
magnesium supplement that includes seven
unique forms of magnesium by optimizer
sounds like a transformer it's not it's
something that you need for your sleep
magnesium breakthrough is 100 organic
and made with vegetarian non-gmo
ingredients in fact i would take it
myself if it was kosher
if it was kosher i think this was
written for ben shapiro um for but it is
important to read kosher for an
exclusive offer for my listeners go to
magbreakthrough.com forward slash walsh
and use walsh10 during checkout to save
10
the first problem with obama's raucous
opulent 60th birthday party this past
weekend is that he's a grown man
throwing a birthday party for himself as
i have long argued nobody should have a
birthday party between the ages of 16
and 100 before that point and after you
may be excused for wanting your friends
and family to celebrate you for simply
living another year but in between
your birthday party such as is as it is
should consist of eating a piece of cake
opening a card with a 50 gift card to
chili's and that's it the whole ceremony
should last no more than 25 minutes and
everybody can get back to their lives
that anyway is my approach to birthdays
but as mentioned it certainly was not
obama's
the daily wire reports photos and videos
were leaked from former president barack
obama's 60th birthday party of the
weekend despite a photography ban that
was implemented for those who were
invited
quote celebrities politicians and couple
hundred other close friends and family
members
packed in to celebrate former president
barack obama's 60th birthday saturday in
what was billed as a scaled back bash
amid rising concerns about the fast
spreading delta variant of covet
according to new york post yet a-lister
streamed into martha's vineyard for the
swanky soiree at obama's 12 million
seaside mansion and few were spotted
wearing masks rapper trap beckham and
manager tj chapman allegedly snapped and
posted images from the birthday bash and
were later forced to delete a separate
report from the daily mail stated that
hundreds of people attended the event
which comes after reports said that it
was supposed to be significantly scaled
back from nearly 500 guests and roughly
200 event staff
now um
we should note that as it is noted there
the naria mask was seen in any of the
leaked footage from the birthday
extravaganza hundreds of people packed
together including prominent figures
from dc and hollywood dancing and
carrying on
spraying their unmasked fumes on one
another and as they did this of course
states across the country are
reinstating mask mandates lockdowns are
coming next
millions of children also will be
subjected to these regulations as they
return to school if they return to
school
and meanwhile countless americans have
lost their businesses elderly people in
nursing homes have been forced to die
alone by the thousands with no contact
with their families average people
forced to endure unspeakable hardship
all in the name of covid's safety while
the elites
the very people pushing these policies
and instating them
party it up on martha's vineyard but
don't worry though the white house
correspondent for the new york times
went on cnn yesterday and explained why
this is all actually okay listen
other people said you know this is
really being overblown
they're following all the safety
precautions people are going to sporting
events that are bigger than this
this is going to be safe this is a
sophisticated vaccinated crowd and and
this is just about optics it's not about
safety
ah yes
the greatest protection from the virus
is
sophistication i guess that's why
according to studies i've read nobody
has ever gotten coveted while sitting in
an expensive leather chair and reading
19th century french literature while
classical music is playing in the
background nobody ever has according to
studies that i made up but then again
that's a different kind of
sophistication than the sophistication
of a 60 year old man dancing to rap
music at his birthday party so i don't
know i guess we'll need some more
studies to sort all of this out in any
case
obviously many people are quite upset
about the perceived double standard on
display here but
it's important to keep a couple of
things in mind
first
um
this is not really a double standard at
all
the message from the elites is quite
simple and remarkably consistent they
are better than than us they are more
important
they reside on a different and more
significant plane of existence
the rules are for us not them they're
very clear about that
you see it it doesn't matter if we are
deprived of life's joys or even life's
necessities
or if it matters it doesn't matter that
much
so let's be fair about that they're
they're not saying it doesn't matter at
all they're just saying it doesn't
matter that much it's not it's not a big
concern
like you you might see a mouse in a cage
and feel a little bad
that all it has is some water and maybe
an old cardboard tube to run through
and you might feel kind of bad it's like
you think what kind of life would that
be
but then you figure it can manage it can
make do because it's a mouse
and you are you you wouldn't want to
live that way but it's just a mouse
obama and his friends feel about us
how we feel about the mouse
they
look down on us in our cage and say ah
poor things trapped in there
well it's probably for the best anyway
back to the party
and then that's what they do they get
back to dancing and sipping their 40
cocktails
this is not a double standard really
it's it's one standard the standard is
important people can do important people
things
unimportant people
can make do with their cage
they're not going to come out and say
that exactly but they'll get pretty damn
close to saying it if you pay attention
one other point
um rather than
wasting energy
getting mad at obama and his ilk
i think it's better to emulate them at
least in one way
do as they do you know live as they live
you might not have their financial means
and hopefully you don't share their
moral derangement or their belief that
most of the world's population is
sub-human and inferior to yourself
hopefully you don't share that part but
you should follow their lead at least in
this respect they clearly are not
worried about covid they never have been
they want you to fear it but they don't
they're living their lives
they always have been living their lives
they never stopped
this has been the case all along we keep
seeing these stories about birthday
parties and celebrations and having
banquets and everything
they want you to cower and shake in fear
locking yourself away hiding behind a
muzzle whenever you leave the house but
that's not how they conduct themselves
you know they are living normally
so should you
now
i don't know if this will make you feel
better or not
but you should realize
that covet is probably endemic at this
point
and what that means is it's not going
anywhere
we will always have it with us
what's more you're going to get covered
if you haven't already
you are going to get it you will
now they tell us now that even the
vaccinated are getting it in large
numbers
that's what they're telling us so
everyone's getting it everyone will get
it
so what are you worried about what is
there to be anxious about anxiety comes
from the unknown
when you don't know what's going to
happen that's what makes people anxious
you walk into a dark room you can't see
anything you don't know what's in there
that's why people are anxious in the
dark
but this is not an unknown
there's a lot of certainty here
almost the sort of comforting certainty
it's out there and you'll get it you'll
get a lot of other stuff too you'll get
cancer eventually 100 guaranteed you
will get cancer unless you die first
that's the only way out
and you will die
as i've tried to remind you many times
you will die you will suffer and you
will die and you cannot escape it
this is the life you were born into
all living beings were born into it what
makes us unique is that we're aware of
our situation we know that we'll die we
can count the days we can see the graves
and know that soon we'll be in one
so there are two paths you can take once
you've contemplated these facts and you
should contemplate them
one is to hide away to be paralyzed in
fear
to be so worried about protecting your
life that you don't do anything with it
treating life like some sort of
collector's item keeping it up in the
you know keeping it in the package up on
the shelf
out of harm's way
just useless up there
the other path is to go outside feel the
sun breathe the air live your life while
you can because what else is there to do
with it
the elites in this country have
certainly chosen that path
they get a lot of other things wrong
i wouldn't suggest modeling yourself
after them in any way except that they
are living their lives
while telling you to go and walk the
other path
don't listen to them
do as they do on this point
not as they say
now let's get to our five headlines
and now time to check in with rock otto
i don't know if i've ever mentioned this
to you before but
why go
to the auto parts store when you can
just go to rockauto.com especially when
it's so hot outside
mosquitoes are going crazy i mean i
really just wa i avoid the outside right
now i'm i'm more of a hermit than usual
but just walking from my car to the door
i'll get attacked by about 56 mosquitoes
one more reason that you want to stay
inside and if you need auto parts pull
out your phone go on your laptop and go
to rockauto.com they always have the
lowest prices possible and you know if
you see it on rockauto.com you're
getting the best selection you're
getting the lowest prices and whatever
it is there it's the best you're going
to get and it's always very good they're
a family business they've been serving
auto parts customers online for 20 years
go to rockauto.com to shop for auto and
body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog is uh
very extensive it's unique and very easy
to navigate at the same same time all
you got to do is plug in your vehicle
you can choose the brand specifications
and prices you prefer and it's as easy
as that so go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck and write walsh and then how did
you hear about us box so they know that
we sent you
all right let's jump right into this
because i'm i
am excited about this and i saw this
video on friday shortly after the show
wrapped and i've just been waiting
for monday so that i if you haven't seen
it i could play it for you and we can
give this uh this gentleman
the credit he deserves so before we play
the the clips here
here's the post from the the the
headline from the new york post says
store owner gets in heated exchange with
transgender woman over offensive sign
it's a defensive sign we're told that's
a many headlines saying that offensive
he's being offensive
and then we're told the owner of a
washington state star wars memorabilia
store got caught on video having a
shouting match with a transgender
politician who confronted him over
signing his window that said if you're
born with a penis you are not a chick
only they use the word for penis that
rhymes with uh with chick
if you're born with that you're not a
chick that's that's what the sign said
that's the offensive sign it's a
that that's that is
a plain fact
so this man already here's what we know
about this man
um he believes in in the truth
and he's uh
he's an advocate for science education
because that's what that cited is
educating you on a a
unavoidable fact of biological science
but the article goes on says tessa
mesquez a council
woman quote unquote in the town of
aberdeen stormed into the sucher and
sons star wars shop and had words with
owner don sucher on wednesday over the
handwritten message that he posted
according to king five tv
um you could see and we'll play the
video here this is where the video picks
up
mescus comes in
is shouting at sucher saying trans women
are women women so on and so forth very
offended by the sign
and uh that's where the video picks up
and we'll play it right now here it is
[Music]
you know what nobody confronts you
that's the problem really if they'd say
really what the do you want a bet what
the issue
in this now you do that do you know why
every time some bull like this happens
my sales go up because people
are wanting this really really really
we're going to show them the side of you
and you do it you
you are not you're not a woman you don't
look like a woman you don't act like a
woman really
you're
in the head what's wrong with you
i am i am confronting you yes that you
are
oh man that is
uh this guy i want to adopt him as my
grand i want him to adopt me and be my
grandfather that's what i want
um and he's a and this is a the guy a
guy who owns a star wars memorabilia
shop i mean this is i i am finding unity
with someone who's a who's dedicated
their life to being a star wars fan
what does that tell you
and that's i i i unironically i i don't
even mean this as a joke i am dead
serious if i was president united states
i would give him the medal of freedom
and if it was up to me i'd nominate him
for a nobel peace prize i really would
because i of course am as fed up with
this as he is
and this is what i've been this is what
we're talking about talk about the last
week we always talk about it that this
this is the point people people need to
reach this point
where you're not going to cower and back
down someone comes in there and they get
in your face this offends me i don't
like it
i don't care this is the truth it's just
the truth
you're not going to scare me and because
here's here's what makes this video so
refreshing
the the beginning part of it
we've seen that a million times
right we've seen it a million times
where someone in in with someone in the
protected class
and the most protected class of all is
quote unquote trans women
men who identify as women the most
protected of all
and once they have spoken
that is supposed to be the end of the
conversation
once they come along and say oh um what
you just said offends me then your
response is supposed to be well never
mind whatever i said it was wrong i'm so
sorry i beg for your forgiveness please
forgive me
and so
we've seen the beginning of the video
where the person comes in and confronts
and says this offends me
the rest of that is not usually how that
ends because usually the person who is
the offender the supposed offender then
they start then they collapse into a
puddle and they beg for forgiveness
and this guy just stands there and says
i don't care whatever
it's truth
you say you're a woman
you're wearing a dress
but you're not
you're not a woman you just aren't that
is not true
uh it even gets better though another
quick clip here
as the as the confrontation moves from
inside the comic book or the member
sorry the memorabilia store and it go it
spills outside and uh they continue
and this is where um the trans person
tells
our friend don that hey this really
hurts my feelings and i don't i don't
like how this makes me feel what you're
saying
and here's uh don's response to that
let's watch
and some people think it's hurtful well
told us that this hurt but here's the
thing i don't give about feelings
anymore i'm 70 a.m eight i went to
vietnam to fight for all
do you think i care about some
feelings absolutely
not thank you sir
that's it
and this is especially what we need we
need
you know and and i hate to say this i i
wish that my generation or the younger
generations could stand up against that
but there but unfortunately there are so
few of us that are that are that even
have our
our heads screwed on correctly with this
um
and in the younger generations i mean
they've been indoctrinated into this
from from from infancy so it's almost
hopeless what we really need
is sort of like the final service that
uh that that generation can perform for
us and they've done and they've
performed many other services
we really need them to just stand up and
say you know
i got nothing this is crazy i know it's
crazy i'm in my 70s
you know i'm not you know i'm i'm i'm
reaching the end of my life here
eventually
and this is just nuts what do i got to
lose and that's this guy's out here 78
as he says he's he's 70 bleeping eight
years old
what does he got what are you gonna take
from him
he runs a star wars shop
what do you have over his head
but you see even and that's how
pervasive this has become that even this
kind of altercation between a much older
person
who has lived they've lived their entire
life for the first you know this guy the
first 70 years of his life
there was no discussion at all about
whether or not a man in a dress is
actually a woman it was not even
discussed
we didn't talk about it
and then in his seventh decade all of a
sudden he's supposed to change what he
has known to be true for the past for
the previous seven decades
and at least he's willing to stand there
and say no
you talk now you can't just come along
here and expect me to after 78 years to
abandon everything i know about reality
because of because you're upset
and he's willing to say that but so many
people
this is not just a younger person
problem older people too
i mean this country is still being run
largely by people in their 70s
and they've all bought in
joe biden is 78 years old
and he's running he's you know he might
as well dye his hair pink at this point
running around south
for his his rhetoric at 78 joe biden he
sounds like a 19 year old gender studies
major
and that's the case for so many people
but at least here's one guy willing to
um
simply speak the simple truth it it's
it's sad
that
this is a notable event at all that i
got to spend that i'm spending 10
minutes talking about it
there should be nothing notable about
this whatsoever this is a rational guy
being confronted by an irrational person
and simply speaking some really basic
fundamental truth about reality
and that should be that
that should be there should be nothing
notable about that
but it is because there are so few
people
who are willing to do that these days
so don sutra american hero
um let's make him president yeah we're
electing 78 year olds these days so why
not him
let's see moving on vice president
camilla harris recorded a video to
address the texas voting law the one
that texas democrats fled the state to
avoid and ended up spreading covet all
over the eastern seaboard in the process
but here's what harris has to say about
that let's watch
i have often thought these past months
about what exactly president johnson
would think about what's going on
especially here in texas
a state that was as sacred to him as the
vote is to democracy
every iteration of the texas bill
would in some way limit
vote by mail
drive through voting and make it
otherwise more difficult to vote
there are similar bills being considered
in many other states bills that would
severely limit the options voters have
to vote
to make it more difficult for them to
vote
and here's the truth
not everyone can stand in line for hours
to vote in person on election day
nor should they have to
americans deserve options to be able to
cast their ballot
and that is why president joe biden and
i are calling on congress to pass the
for the people act
and the john lewis voting rights
advancement act
not everyone can wait in line for hours
on election day really who can't
who is not able to do that
who exactly are you referring to
um
okay i can think of one category
service members members of the military
who are overseas
i mean they literally cannot it's just
not not possible they wouldn't be
allowed to leave they'd be prevented by
the government from doing that
um so that is there's there's one group
a you know people deployed overseas by
the united states government in the
military
they are being prevented by the
government from going and voting in
person
which makes sense because you can't
obviously ship them all back home to
vote and then back again wouldn't be
very efficient so there's one group okay
fine
you got absentee voting for that um
who else though
who who are these other people
of the people who live here in the
united states and are not deployed
overseas on some sort of
uh military mission
who are the people who can't stand in
line
or sit in line
wait in line in whatever manner or
fashion you prefer you can lie on the
ground if you want to probably
i wouldn't recommend it but you probably
could
who are the people that can't carve out
and you can't tell me why would it be
people that have jobs that day
i get it i have a job i work during the
day but you it's not like you wake up
one day
and you turn on the news and they say oh
election it's election time everyone get
out there and vote
we decided to move it up a year and a
half randomly just yeah kind of keep
things fresh
no that doesn't happen you know exactly
when voting day is going to be you know
years in advance
so if you want to vote and your your the
hours at your job wouldn't normally
allow it you've got years ahead of time
to ask for that time off
and many employers are
happy to give the time off for to go
vote even the ones that aren't again you
could if you want to go vote you need to
use some time out you got you got plenty
of time in advance to plan for this and
to make sure that you could do it
if it's really a priority
now you might say
um
well it's not worth it to me like i
don't want to i don't want to take a
couple hours i only get so many hours
that i get off every year i don't want
to i don't even want to use three hours
of my time to go vote
or it's in the middle of the week i've
got other things i want to do it's just
it's just not worth it to me to just to
carve out that time
well then i would say apparently voting
isn't all that important to you
and that's fine
as you know i am unlike most people when
it comes to this i'm not going to sit
here and shame you if you were to just
come out and admit and say it's not that
important to me you know i'll vote if if
um
if if they make it so easy that i almost
that it's
that even i would be convinced to do it
then maybe i'll do it but but other than
that i just don't care that much
i'm not going to shame you for that
i'm not going to sit here and say voting
is a sacred right that all americans
must participate
our forefathers died so that you could
go to the polls and vote no they didn't
really
actually
they they didn't they didn't uh have in
mind that that literally every single
person without any restriction
whatsoever
no matter how clueless they are
or or how much they they
what what would it you know how much
they do or don't contribute to society
that everyone would go vote that was
never the idea
so i'm not going to say that you just
come out admit it's not that important
to me fine then stay home perfectly fine
that's a reasonable choice i'd rather go
to work that day than vote cool
but if it's this important if that's
what you believe if you believe it's a
sacred right it's the most important
thing in the world blah blah blah etc
then i don't see why people can't carve
out the time given how much notice we
have
you could plan right now okay here we
are in 2021 you want to vote next year
in the midterms you want to vote in uh
the we're talking presidential election
you want to vote 2024. you got three
years to get planning
i'm sure you can handle it
all right um next here there's
increased panicking at least in the
media and they want panicking the media
is pretending to panic and they want the
rest of us to panic
over
um
the
alleged case of children filling up the
hospitals because of covet that's what
we're being told
now here's another article from the new
york post that says pediatric hospitals
in florida have become completely
overwhelmed quote unquote
with young patients battling cover 19
amid the spread of the highly contagious
delta variant a doctor says
you always love that when they put that
at the end of the statement they make
their shocking claim
and then you get to the end comma
a random person says
the grim development comes as florida
the grim alleged about development so
i'm going to add that in there comes as
florida on sunday reported having the
highest number of children 172
hospitalized with the chronovirus
according to data from the us department
of health and human services
okay but even right there hundreds this
is what they are we're being told
um
172 children hospitalized with the
chronovirus in the entire state of what
is it like 20 million people in the
entire state
even if that number is accurate
that overwhelms the hospitals
in a state of 20 million people
172 children are sick and that that
overwhelms the system
is what you're telling us
we're some kind of like third world
country we can't even we can't deal with
that
it's an overwhelming situation
what the heck happens in a bad flu flu
season
we're not prepared for those realities
at all
um dr eileen marty says the number of
cases in our hospitals and children
the number of cases in our hospitals in
children and our children's hospitals
are completely overwhelmed
let's say this doesn't really make any
sense at all the numbers of cases in our
hospitals in children and our children
hospitals are completely overwhelmed
what
um
she said quote rpd this is this was her
talking to cnn oddly enough
she gave this interview to cnn i could i
went on online to try to find the clip
of this actual interview so i could play
it for you and i couldn't find it maybe
i was possible i didn't look hard enough
i only took a few minutes to look but i
wasn't able to find it so i'm just
reading it to you now
our pediatricians the nursing the staff
are exhausted and the children are
suffering and it is absolutely
devastating our children are very much
affected we've never seen numbers like
this before sharp rises in hospital
emissions involving kids with coco 19
have been recorded in other states too
including arkansas which had its own
record number of children when they
hospitalized with the virus
and but this all comes from one doctor
who says that the the children's
hospitals are overwhelmed
with
covet cases
and it's important to know she says that
they're overwhelmed with covet
because we do know and i guess we're
supposed to believe this is some kind of
coincidence
there are other
viruses and diseases among children that
are spiking right now
that send children to hospitals
rsv for example there was a headline um
on um
the time magazine had a headline just a
couple of weeks ago july 22nd saying
uh why the respiratory disease rsv is
having an off-season surge and it's all
about how this disease is surging i
we've had of our four kids two of them
have had our end up in the hospital with
rsv especially with babies it's a very
serious illness you take it very
seriously we've gone to the hospital
with two kids because of rsv
and if there's a surge in rsv cases i
can see how that would lead to um
to hospitals
seeing an unusual number of patients
still
it's in a state with 20 million people
an unusual number of cases should not
overwhelm the hospitals
but then again we have to keep in mind
that the word overwhelm that's not like
a scientific word
that's kind of a g that's subjective
that's a judgment
um so we know that that's happening
and when the media reports that hot that
children's hospitals are allegedly
overwhelmed
are they including that in the picture
and not telling us that's could very
well be the
case but we also have to keep in mind we
have one one doctor in florida who's
gone on the record and said that
children's hospitals specifically are
overwhelmed from
covid
not from anything else
and she's the one doctor to say that in
the state we haven't heard from any
others that have said that as far as i
know
and that conflicts with everything we've
seen in the data from the very beginning
we could run through all the numbers
again i think it's off the top of my
head
um the mortality rate in children from
coronavirus because there's been 41 you
know almost 42 million cases
and the number of children that have
died is like three you know 300 less
than 400 so far um
and that means that point i think it's
point zero zero eight percent of
children have died from covid
very very sad when any child dies of
anything very sad when anyone dies of
anything especially when it's a child
but that rate of death is extremely low
thank god it's so low
we know the hospitalization rate
is not quite that low but it's pretty
it's extremely low as well
all of the data from the very beginning
has told us this and yet we have one
doctor
who makes a claim that contradicts that
that is not what you would expect to see
based on all the data we have
and of course that doctor ends up in the
headlines her claim ends up making a
headline
unqualified headlines florida florida
children's hospitals filling up
overwhelmed
all right uh what else we got here
okay i want to tell you about this story
because this is just um
remarkable in a lot of bad ways this
report is from khq in washington um
local news affiliate down there it says
there's no question that shane goldsby
assaulted and killed robert munger
inside the airway heights correctional
center the question is why were they
assigned to live together in the same
prison cell monger a 70 year old
convicted child rapist
died after goldsby hit monger in the
face and head around a hunt about 14
times
stomped on his head at least four times
and kicked a couple more times before
walking away and being taken into
custody by correction guards
munger was convicted on multiple child
molestation charges in 2019 he was
sentenced to 43 years in prison
um sex offenders are considered marked
men in state prisons nationwide like in
california where sex offenders are
killed in prison at a rate that is
double the national average
um what about the risk though when a sex
offender is put in the same cell with
their victim's older brother now this is
the part
that is hard to believe but this is
what's being reported and there are some
sources for it it says goldsby um
goldsby himself also cindy elliott who's
the mother
of um
the mother of gold's been also the
mother of the child that was reportedly
victimized by monger and an anonymous
tipster said that munger raped goldsby's
little sister who was still a minor
the reporter says i talked to goldsby
who is currently in uh the jail facing a
new charge pretend premeditated murder
and then he goes on he talks about he
says
what he claims and they've got
apparently three sources and this has
now been reported by multiple media
outlets
that um
shane goldsby
was put in a prison cell with this
monger guy
and munger not only a serial child
rapist that we know for sure
convicted of that
but apparently according to his reports
he he actually raped
goldsby's little sister and
told him about it
monger the rapist told goldsby and
started taunting him
with details of his little sister's rape
and
also apparently reportedly
goldsby went to
the prison officials and he went through
the process of trying to get transferred
to a new cell and they wouldn't transfer
him and finally he says he just snapped
and he had enough of it and he
beat the guy to death
and now he's getting 25 years in prison
for that
um
this is sort of an easy case for me to
adjudicate personally because
even without the detail of
this guy raping goldsby's little sister
even taking that aside
um i wouldn't give him 25 years in
prison
even if he was just sort of generally
angry and upset that this man is a
serial child rapist
i'm not giving you 25 years in prison
for that
i mean if anything i'm thinking about an
early release
because of that
and i and i again this is that is also
not a joke i actually i kind of mean
that sincerely i
th this is why and if you don't like it
you say well we can't have vigilante
killings and stuff like that in prison
and i mean and you're right from a
reasonable perspective you can't have
that for the sake of the
of um
of the safety of everyone in the prison
not not the child rapist but everyone
including the prison guards you can't
just you know allow peop allow the
inmates to kill each other willy-nilly
in the prison yard but
um
if if we're saying
that child rapists are
so heinous
and such absolute monstrous scumbags
that you can't even put them around
other scumbags
you can't even put them around murderers
and people that have done other horrible
things but not that horrible
like even those people don't want to be
around someone like that
then i think that tells us that this is
the kind of crime where if you commit
that we should probably rather than
leaving the inmates to take care of it
probably the state should take care of
it
you see you lock that person in in a
cell on death row
and then
you take care of them that way there
should be that should be an execution
i think that's a that's a pretty good
way to judge these things
if it's the kind of crime
where we cannot put you in with general
population because they would be so
disgusted by you
that they wouldn't be able to stop
themselves from killing you
then probably that might not work this
way every time depends on what the crime
is that's a pretty good indication that
you should be eligible for death row
it is crazy to me
that
even in states where we still have
capital punishment
in no state
that i'm aware of can you be executed
for simply raping a child
that's the idea well if you just do that
then we're not going to execute you you
have to you have to you have to also
kill someone
as long as you haven't killed anyone
then you're not gonna be eligible for
death row
so you could have someone
who murdered one person
they they go on death row i'm fine with
that
um
and then you could have someone else who
let's say raped 40 kids
no death row for them because everyone
physically survived it
emotionally mentally psychologically
it's another story but physically
everyone survived it
even if barely
and that's not going to be eligible for
death row that to me doesn't make any
sense there's no justice in that
whatsoever
then you add in the detail about his
sister here's what i'll say the person
who should be doing if we're given 25
years to anybody it should be the prison
officials responsible for putting this
poor guy in a cell
with the the monster who raped his
sister
that's the person we give 25 years to
for shane goldsby you know
at worst here's what i at at worst if
you feel like you have to do something
you give them you give them a slap on
the wrist
maybe a literal slap on the wrist you
say hey don't do that don't kill child
rapists we don't do that here no no no
then send him about his day
all right let's move on to reading the
youtube comments
this is from malachi interesting
comments says matt leaving aside
specific situations i think you're
making a strategic error in repeatedly
urging people to unilaterally speak out
in the present environment each person
who unilaterally speaks out ends up
being destroyed
losing their job etc each such daily
cancellation just serves as a powerful
reminder to everybody else to shut up or
face dire consequences shades of gulag
archipelago your faulty advice is akin
to having having an army of millions of
soldiers and then ordering them to line
up and march out single file one by one
minute after minute into
gatling gun fire um attacking in this
way the outcome is clear we see it daily
each of your soldiers gets killed one by
one and moreover the residual soldiers
still waiting in line wait in silent
fear what is necessary ultimately is
coordinated protest slash responses such
as boycotts and the imposition of
large-scale negative consequences on the
other side when they cancel without
valid reason until they face coordinated
negative consequences they have nothing
to fear in firing away
well you raise plenty of good points and
i don't i don't think this has to be an
either or proposition
i think coordinated campaigns are good
boycotts have a place i don't know how
effective they ultimately are but i'm
not against them in principle so there's
a place for that um i think we have to
do that
but
but also there's nothing that can
replace
just ordinary people living their
everyday lives
according to their principles and not
being afraid to speak them and live
according to them
because if we're not going to do that
then all the boycotts in the world won't
mean a damn thing
and the other thing to remember here is
you're saying well we don't want one and
one one in a person we don't want to
send them in front of the firing line
well i get that but i'm not talking
about us all taking turns
i'm not saying that we each take turns
and i say well today is my day to live
according to convictions and to live
like i have common sense and i
understand basic truths about science
and morality and so on this is my turn
tomorrow you'll do it tomorrow you know
we have like a seating chart or
something i'm not saying that
i'm saying all of us together should be
doing that
don
sucher okay yeah i mean he put the sign
out in his on his uh on his uh
storefront
so he put himself out there a little bit
but other than that you know he's not
he's as far as i know he's not walking
around in in his daily life
looking for confrontation except for the
little sign he put on his on his uh
store which is just a funny sign
but when someone came up to him and
expected him to cower and back down
and abandon common sense and truth and
reason he just said no i'm not going to
that's it i'm not going to
my point is we should all be living that
way right now all together
and if we all did that
and responded to those kinds of
situations the way that don sucher did
it it would make an enormous difference
and there's no replacing that there is
no coordinated effort that will replace
that
because we again we can have all the
boycotts in the world but if we're all
living in such a way
that someone can come up to us in our
personal lives and hector us into
abandoning truth and reason if that's
what we're all gonna do in our personal
lives the boycotts don't mean a damn
thing
because the enemy has still won
you know you then then the boycott or
whatever you're talking about here
becomes like a runner-up prize just
making ourselves feel a little bit
better
but we've still lost
because in you know in the way that we
live our lives we have abandoned what we
know to be true we cannot do that
so we should all be doing it together
and how do you encourage people to to do
it well you know
there
many times
there have to be at least some people
who are willing to charge out into the
fire first
to
embolden everybody else i mean someone
has to go otherwise everyone's just
going to be cry you know crouched down
in the trenches afraid to get up and and
make a charge
so there have to be some of us who are
willing to just go for it
at the beginning
and then hopefully everyone else joins
in
and if they don't then shame on them
then they've given up and the war is
lost and that's it
um larry says the black plague was hard
to miss without mass media where i live
covet is hard to notice the sickness in
blue cities is very apparent
uh yeah yeah i hear this a lot and it's
sort of an interesting thing
of course it's anecdotal i don't know
how much you can really take from it but
um i hear a lot from people they say hey
you know i don't know anyone who has
died from covet or even been seriously
ill from code i hear that's the case for
me i don't know a single person
i certainly don't know anyone who's died
of covet i don't know anyone who was in
the hospital with kovid
um i know some people have had it but it
was basically mild
mild to moderate that's that's all i've
seen
and there are a lot of people in in the
same
boat um
and that's one of the reasons why the
media has to go
overboard in convincing you to be afraid
of it because if you just went based on
your own experience you would say yeah
this is a sickness
it's uh it makes it it's it's not fun to
deal with but it's not um
it's not anything for me to cower my in
my house over
so but again i mean i
that that also is a reflection on
of just how comfortable we are in our
lives because i also don't know that
many people who have died of anything
at this point in my life i know some but
not many
and that's very different you know i'm
35 years old if i was 35 years old
living at any other point in history
prior to modern times at this point in
my life i would probably have had at
least one child who had died both my
parents will be dead for sure by now um
i i would have seen plenty of death and
and destruction all around me
um so
and that goes back to the fact that we
all live this way insulated from death
and then this thing intrudes into our
our lives and forces people to confront
death and that's where they become so
afraid they don't know how to deal with
it they have no frame of reference
um
let's see bobby says hey matt i was on a
15 hour road trip over the last few days
and i listened to your show for at least
10 of those hours thanks for keeping me
sane and entertained
so you spent
you spent five hours not listening to
the show
how dare you sir you're banned
of course
and beth says can the sweet babies get a
sarcastic reading of vax that thing up
well i wouldn't dream of being sarcastic
about something like this okay something
that combines the two things that i care
the most about vaccines and juveniles i
would never be sarcastic but if you want
to hear the lyrics of that song um uh
here they are
you fit in the online date yeah fine to
mate yeah
open up blk yeah okay yeah
profile pic looking tight yeah
nice yeah
got your boy reading right yeah precise
yeah
but before you find a date yet you gotta
wait yeah
gotta go vaccinate yeah get it straight
yeah
girl you looks good won't you vax that
thing up here's a handsome young brother
won't you vax that thing up
dating real life you need to fax that
thing
feeling freaky all night
you need to vax that thing up
i know you can't stand it no holding
hands chick but when we get the shot
we're gonna be romance girl you can be
the queen after quarantine we can meet
him at the spot and we can do the thing
internet date yeah i'm the mate yeah
download the app shorty
you ain't got to wait there
i love it when you hold me
eggplant emoji
you can be the young hot thing
i'd be the og
[Music]
it's just beautiful
beautiful even somehow i thought the
original
back that up could not ever be topped
and then i found out that they were
going for the remix and i thought
there's no way this is like trying to
remake the godfather
it's a to repaint the mona lisa
it cannot possibly capture that same
beauty and majesty once again and um and
and i was wrong and so that's the last
time i will ever doubt
the artist known as juvenile
you know america has reached a breaking
point where the onus is on the people to
stand up and say no to the
authoritarianism creeping into our
country under the leadership of our new
administration
i don't like where this is headed but
thankfully ben shapiro wrote an
excellent intensely researched now
best-selling book about it and it's
best-selling for a reason you could find
out that reason for yourself by just
picking up a copy of the authoritarian
moment
and unfortunately for all of us this
book could not be more timely but
fortunately for us it gives you
everything you need to know about
authoritarianism where it comes from
what's happening right now and what we
can do about it the authoritarian moment
is now available at amazon barnes noble
or any other major bookseller so go and
get your copy now also if there's one
person that's always trending for her
controversial and thought-provoking
takes it is candace owens and now
you can have a chance to meet her and
hear her drop those truth bombs live and
in her studio audience if you sign up
now as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 25 off your new membership
and be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip for two to the
daily wire studios in nashville to see
candace live dropping those bombs as the
kids would say not only will you meet
candace herself you'll be getting an
inside look at her studio and front row
seats to watch her destroy the less
insidious ideology on her talk show
candace so get a great deal on a new
daily wire membership at dailywire.com
subscribe with code vip and 25 office
you automatically will be entered for a
chance to win the vip experience now
let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we have the distinct honor and
pleasure of canceling nike of course
nike provides us with many reasons to
cancel it the sweatshops and forced
labor would certainly make the list but
today i'm charging them with a crime
almost as serious as those that is the
crime of cringe nike has extensive
experience with producing cringe of all
types especially in commercial form
but none of their cringe offerings have
ever quite reached the level of this
commercial which they just released in
honor of the women's olympic basketball
team winning another gold medal
when you hear that the women's olympic
basketball team won a gold medal i'm
sure your first thought is
wait the women have their own olympic
basketball team
i was just as surprised as you
apparently this team not only exists but
has had a lot of success on the world
stage which brings back the old the
age-old riddle you know if women win a
basketball game in the forest and nobody
watches did the game really happen
some philosophers say no but the
philosophers at nike say yes in fact
nike goes quite a bit beyond that not
willing to settle with the typical girl
power virtue signaling the company put
out an ad unironically claiming
that the women's olympic basketball
squad due to its prowess in defeating
teams of five foot six-inch females is
the greatest dynasty of all time
and by the way i'm not kidding about the
height they beat japan for the gold and
a quarter of japan's roster is five and
a half feet or shorter
they actually had one lady on the court
who was five foot four inches
their tallest player was seven inches
shorter than our tallest player
and that's not to take anything away
from
the u.s women's olympic basketball team
well maybe it takes a little bit away
but mainly it's just to say to nike hey
slow your roll a little bit because this
might be overkill let's watch
today i have a presentation on dynasties
but i refuse to talk about the ancient
history and drama that's just the
patriarchy instead i'm going to talk
about a dynasty that i actually look up
to
an all-women dynasty
women of color
gay women
women who fight for social justice women
with a jump shot a dynasty that makes
your favorite men's basketball football
and baseball teams look like amateurs a
dynasty with fire braids a dynasty with
sick style a dynasty with crazy dimes a
dynasty that makes alexandra great look
like alexander thief okay
the dynasty that's been raining for the
past 25 years undefeated since 96
the usa basketball women's national team
seven time consecutive gold medalists
and most importantly
women that make it possible for girls
like me to feel like they can be a part
of whatever dynasty they want
the greatest
dynasty ever
[Music]
if i was a teacher and a t and a kid
handed in that assignment i would expel
them from school
if i had that authority
but who can argue with that i mean 12
women playing in a basketball tournament
where nobody knows how to dunk are more
impressive than a man who conquered most
of the known world and reshaped the
globe and became one of the most
consequential humans to ever live on the
planet all before the age of 32. i mean
who can argue who can argue that the
women's basketball team makes all men's
teams and all sports look like amateurs
you know better even than the dream team
or the o7 patriots or the 96 bulls or
the 98 yankees or the 85 bears and this
is the case even though the women's
basketball team would be thoroughly
destroyed by a team of actual amateur
men in fact an above average boys high
school team would easily defeat the
women's olympic team and the score would
not be close
but sure yeah those women are the most
spectacular and imposing collection of
human beings ever assembled on planet
earth who could argue
well i suppose anybody with a
rudimentary knowledge of sports history
or world history or simply current
events could argue
though perhaps they won't argue for fear
of being called sexist
now you could say that this is just a
bit of hyperbole meant to motivate and
excite the 30 or 40 girls in the country
who are in the market for basketball
shoes
uh more importantly you might speculate
nike is trying to signal to our cultural
overlords that it's on their side please
forgive us for the sweatshop and slavery
stuff don't you see we're saying nice
things about women
not just women but women of color and
gay women
these women are really good at
basketball
really good
not impressed yet i mean okay well these
women are the best basketball players of
all time no no they're the best athletes
of all time no no wait we can do better
they're the greatest humans who have
ever lived anywhere on planet earth do
you like us yet are you satisfied will
you be our friend are we woke enough
all other humans are scum not worthy to
kiss the feet of these wnba players
too far where's the line here just tell
us where the line is and we'll tow it
just tell us
no doubt that's the point still even so
it's worth thinking about i think the
larger societal trends that this
commercial fits in with
for one thing
we see this now familiar zero-sum game
between the sexes
it's not enough to simply say hey nice
job ladies congrats on the gold medal
you did a wonderful job
no in order for women to be appreciated
men must be depreciated
in the eyes of our culture women cannot
be appropriately recognized if men are
also recognized there's only room for
one on the stage
of course as always the ironic effect of
all these over-the-top attempts to
complement women
is that it ends up being quite insulting
to women it's sort of like when my
four-year-old son this weekend was very
proud of himself because he figured out
how to bounce a ball off of the wall and
catch it again
and he showed me and i clapped and i
gave him a high five and i said wow
buddy that's great
and he said isn't that amazing and i
said yeah it's so amazing
in truth of course there was nothing
especially amazing about the achievement
and i would never say this to him but
his older brother was doing that at like
two years old but um this is the kind of
encouragement we give to children
because they're just children
and it's also funny in a cute sort of
way to see them so proud of doing
something so simple it's one thing to
patronize young children this way even
that could go too far and often does
but to go through this routine for grown
women is another thing entirely
most women don't want to be infantilized
like that and the ones who do want to be
infantilized actually need even more to
be treated like adults for their own
betterment
the other trend is the denigration of
course of western civilization's
historical heroes again you might say
that this is just a commercial it's not
that serious and you're right in one
respect but the fact that a commercial
would so casually claim that none of the
great men of history matter at all and
that all of them are oppressive
patriarchal fascists
just tells you how ingrained and
mainstream this stuff really is
i mean it's a bad sign when radical
feminist missingry is used to brainwash
students in a gender studies class it's
an even worse sign when it's used to
sell sneakers
the effect ultimately is to create a
society where people are not only
terminally ungrateful for the
achievements and sacrifices that made it
possible for them to be so spoiled in
the first place but also it leads people
to being extremely dull and boring
alexander the great is a fascinating and
immense figure
you could spend your whole life studying
him and many people have
okay that's how you know you're an
important person
is if you become a subject
in and of yourself
for people thousands of years in the
future to study
and history gives us a window and and
through it we can see many extraordinary
figures and by learning about them and
what they achieved and the lessons they
taught we might inherit just a little
piece of their complexity and their
greatness
now imagine rejecting all of that
and deciding instead that the pinnacle
of human achievement was a women's
basketball team in the year 2021
what a boring world that would be if
that's the best we ever did
what a boring person you must be to see
the world that way and that ultimately
is why i must say to nike today
you are
canceled
and that'll do it for us thanks for
watching thanks for listening have a
great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show was edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode the taliban surges
across afghanistan apple plans to scan
people's cell phones for evidence of
child sexual abuse and schools reopen
amid more coveted concerns join us and
get the facts first on the news you need
to know with our show morning wire